hey guys it's not from the score eSports
the EU LCS team has never been afraid of
injecting some personality into their
broadcast this foot has been no
different in fact they've taken it up a
notch
we've been watching and we've been lovin
it
here are the best moments from this
strange EU LCS broadcast
it's funny because every time to go home
after day after the loss we're like we
should have won this game but we [ __ ]
up and unlike we we messed up sorry some
small things in the game I can't talk
[ __ ] but I'm playing really bad so oh
god another swear word well it's been
the theme of the two days what I didn't
draw one yet nope you didn't so we're
gonna close out the show so you
definitely cannot do that
where's misfits gonna end maybe as soon
as playoffs and what is it that's gonna
make misfits become Sprint's with
champions I mean if you look at our
horrors I've got I've got the best mid
laner and the best support now along
with the best top best jungle and best
eighty ok fine miss miss gaming a team
that many people expect it to be
challenging for the top spot in the EU
LCS now there's a very real possibility
they don't even make craps what went
wrong for misfits and how do they fix it
let's find out what this doctor orders
basically I think we just you know just
make bail
I'm sorry for crashing this but I just
wanted to thank you for seeing my life
at the end stay tuned
great League of Legends and coming for
Wakanda
[Music]
his singh will be joining the Hastur
desk for picks and bans ookay and perks
and you can see that beautiful man on
your screen these are his top MVP you
look service okay let's throw it over to
fix rake off and picked official and hit
syrup I'll take it big Draco's big too
fishy oh it's not a big deal as I've
said big deez but welcome to Berlin in
week 5 of the EU LCS spring split we
have to talk about the diffuser faces in
the crowd there's actually a show so
shout out what is Zach uh well he's
going swimming that's what I know about
this he's got the snorkel yes but why is
needs snorkels he's like well well maybe
blobs need to breathe too apparently
they do yeah hit me see it makes perfect
sense my point yeah I mean he's a giant
walking condom that's what he is so
again don't question legal ladies logic
all right I don't really have any
follow-up questions going into today it
was like oh we're playing it's ok hope
we can win kind of style I want to see
if they if they bounce back please as we
highlight early in the show when they
lost a lot this time which was to be a
good morning sir
excuse me good sir we have a game of
League of Legends to play
but it's up with table nice and yawning
is it that boring to see that apart
yelling thank you for joining us as well
hold your hand please well very good now
I'm here to support you because Trevor's
mean I'm the good [ __ ] I always find a
little bit weird when people say sorry
for their performance I'm like I mean I
do it every single day now if you miss
this folks at home yeah that's gets
their picture on the screen is in charge
so I'm a charge now too fishy Oh also hi
mom if you're watching a doubt it's
let's take a look at the lineup sticking
it up kicking it off on the blue side
it's Giants and when you look at Giants
you have to think about the but a lot of
space above us you didn't have that much
higher gate I got a camera right in
front of me radio fire hello hi hey I
mean that's the same torn class and oh
look at that that Danish chin
[Applause]
[Applause]
g2 esports taking to the rip the first
game the you LCS 2018 and we're doing it
old-school western-style never mind
we're game yes
never mind we're pasta Ken it's an
emotional roller coaster already what
more can you ask for foot let's stop for
some legal legends Plantinga yeah thank
you awnings misfits continuing to wage
this war in the middle lane we've hit
this big game stride that we so often
see and good that we have time to
explain it again a little bit too much
actions so we're gonna slow down if it's
a farce PC again I'm going on that stage
and I'm beating that piece ago hold me
back drink if it is the PC it is the PC
and it is potato you came huh it doesn't
know any better
[Music]
I'm not saying it'll be easy but imagine
if they do it imagine if they win
imagine if the unicorns get to playoffs
because if they do they're the best team
in the European LCS we're gonna reveal
the myth with the winner in just a few
minutes that make sure you get there
make sure that your vote counts because
going by single vote matters it's like
an election control Donald Trump might
win it and that is not good for anyone
we'll have to issue and get to the
action Thank You sharks I am of course
no longer joined by Vettius who saw him
over there at the video wall this o R in
the visual long I thought I was ready as
omen I thought that - you got very mad
at me when I called you Betty I saw fair
that corrected me so to be fair we were
making love so wrong name you weren't
supposed to tell everything my apartment
is painted in the cage
Tellem hour before Phyllis era the off
for the smell was them
Anabelle hella clean akimbo cursed
honoré de Delon envisioned scary Ankush
among vida de Kiev their day
hemlock of broad spin torn for our evil
store Nashawn I'm a little bit dismayed
that you didn't bring me like pulsar or
hotdog or any of these things before the
game [ __ ] fact we have a queue a lot of
takes of the final hotdogs because it
kept falling to the side your hotdog is
a little bit floppy yes yes let's just
say like that
check them out on EU law eSports calm
and in the meantime you can see if you
loved officios meat as much as I do I
know but you can do a little trick is
you can build bringing a little thing
that they can actually sit in like for
taco shells you know we can plow like a
hot dog like casing yeah I guess it's
called a hooker hot rkz now we didn't
have that so I just had to put on the
plate and then whenever I put stuff when
it kept like tipping that makes I so wet
this was probably like maybe shot number
five okay I'm gonna shut you up
stays sheriff is a clutch player and
when their back is against the wall
sheriff always shows up always does good
stuff apparently but that would not have
been possible if there was not a new
sheriff in town you want to know why I
picked h2k there to share big we set it
on the desk I'll say it again pew pew
pew pew pew this guy is so good I think
we're still pretty bad overall but
luckily you were generally in fingers
right now pretty bad
[Music]
one where we lost it everybody was it
close oh my goodness and we keep calling
rocket the kingslayer's no matter who's
on that line up and whenever they played
t2 for some reason they just beat ya you
really called up the kingslayer's if
they're up versus yonkos though that was
my apology it's time to make building
your champions easier
introducing the score eSports new builds
calculator which allows you to plug in
items and runes to figure out which
builds give you the best stats the new
builds page also gathers information on
what the top players and your favorite
pros are building so you'll be able to
try them out yourself take control of
your champion and try out the new
feature on the score eSports build
website by clicking on the link in the
description below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button